someone actually had messaged me and
they said a bye I know you guys are
covering a lot of racial topics but I
know with everything going on it's so
much but I just wish things could go
back to normal
what's so funny you're covering a lot of
racist things you know I mean I wish
things will go back to normal it's
pretty normal as is what when it strikes
me you all if is pretty [ __ ] normal
yes fare to go back to normal we if the
norm is people are saying something
about it was like what was normal
nothing was ever normal yeah yeah these
things were just happening they just
weren't on your screen
you know I fit here's the thing I don't
want to cover this stuff I don't want to
talk about race I don't want to cover
incidents with police officers oh man I
just wanna laugh at cringy stuff talk
about vulnerability and masculinity and
all these other topics that I find her
interesting that's all I want to do all
right I want to post stand-up stuff I
just want that's all I care but
unfortunately we live in a world where
if we don't repost or discuss a tragic
event nothing happens all right take
Brianna Taylor with that no-knock
warrant cops go in there thinking
there's going to be you know narcotics
they don't find anything the people
inside the residence didn't know was
cops so they start using their second
Amendment firing back you know Brianna
the medic she's killed and now because
of all the uproar because everyone's
been so loud about it they are banning
no-knock warrants but without that kind
of social media presence without us
having to constantly hear these stories
and constantly repost things that kind
of legend of legislative change doesn't
happen you know and it's unfortunate but
we've been quiet about a lot of these
topics for a long time and it's led us
here so the idea that by not talking
about it
things will sometimes go back to normal
maybe normal is cool for you maybe
normal sounds great to you but for us
our sense of normal isn't the best and I
think the way we move forward as a world
as societies is that we address art or
are our blind spots we fix our problems
and we all move forward together
but it makes no sense to me to not
discuss these things because I just
don't sleep well if I don't it's
important for us to engage in these
conversations no matter how
uncomfortable no matter how redundant
you know maybe there's another voice
that hasn't heard this perspective maybe
there's another person who needs to hear
it from this perspective I told you
before like I was not like oh I really
didn't like the public outrage thing I
didn't like that like doesn't work while
you're doing that for you're protesting
for what what does it was gonna happen I
was one of those people mmm and then I
saw what happened yeah I'm like oh yeah
wow I was wrong yeah I was dead wrong
cuz the outrage worked that's the reason
why people are being held accountable
public outrage I really was not for it
but then they prove me wrong yeah it's
not a tenable situation we can't keep
relying on public outrage because
there's too many things happening in too
many places and people end up in the
blind spots whether it's white victims
of these issues yellow it doesn't matter
right sometimes end up in the blind spot
but you know when I watch that lost
Vegas video of that guy on the floor who
was basically like please don't please
don't and he still got shot on you know
that disturbed me as well didn't disturb
me any less than any of the black
shootings you know but we have to raise
our voices and we have to say something
we have to because if we don't then this
kind of stuff keeps happening do you
think I like the fact that I had to
watch the Marberry video that should
disturb me but everyone watching it and
reposting it led to charges being filed
within a couple days does that make
sense to you does it make sense to me
but it is the way the system works right
now they shut down the case real quick
real quick yeah and then public outrage
happen yeah I mean we're fighting now
yeah we're fighting you we're finding
new evidence quick thinks you know and
it's not just that there's so many
instances even now Trump is signing an
executive action on an executive order
on police reform now maybe it's not the
best reform maybe not but things are
moving things are changing I'm not okay
with all the changes I'm not for
everything but to think that things can
go back to normal normal for whom normal
for what and is that normal really great
maybe it was for you but I can assure
you for a lot of other people it's an
untenable situation that's why people
are protesting so hard so
just be mindful of that understand that
your discomfort is not more important
than people's right to live and I think
that happen is that when you say that I
want things to go back to normal normal
is really when you didn't hear about it
but I heard about it it was people from
my neighborhood for my families
neighborhoods for my family whether it
was in Canada whether it was in the
States the natives that I know here the
natives that I know over there I heard
stories like that even though it was not
public so normal means you didn't hear
about it but we constantly heard about
something that's happening yeah to one
of our family members or to one of us so
yeah the normal thing it's not really
quite normal yeah yeah and you said it
to me to also like you don't want to
cover this too I don't like but you see
myself you see my face every time you
okay so today's topic and you bring up
that if I see cops and you know if I see
cops in uniform one more time brother
like you see the way I like I'm done
talking about is that we have to talk
you have to talk about it but the thing
is that it's not that the work is not
done
yeah it's not over you don't agree with
Morgan Freeman that in order to remove
racism we have to not talk about it no I
don't agree with it no I understand why
he says it though but no I don't agree
with him yeah I understand that he
doesn't want a Black History Month I
wouldn't want a black black in three
months but we don't live in that world
in that world where we don't need one
unfortunately we do I wish we wouldn't
have to need one yeah I wish but that's
not the state that we lived in hmm you
know when I say that you know black
people are very a viewed as second
citizen a second-class citizen black
people are viewed as second-class
citizen I don't mean that we're actually
are but that's how we reviewed I wish I
wish more of you that way but it is what
it is yeah you know it is frustrating
for me to even discuss race not even
along put police lines but just in
journal might work yes you know when I
go to a comedy club and then the comi
club owner says to me oh I can't have
more than one black guy on the show
because then it becomes a weird show I
was like why not you know I mean like do
you even know what my set entails do you
even know what I'm gonna talk about you
know but just a perception of my
darkness effects
day to day job and I've heard that ruff
ruff how many times have I earned my
spot on a comedy show or like a big you
know big big show at the biggest Comedy
Festival in the world people like yeah
you're just a token dude that's supposed
to be there this what first off we had
the best shot of everyone there but
everything always gets reduced to my
race so you know as much as I'd love to
never talk about it again so press the
world never lets me forget and I tell
this to preach all the time before I
immigrated here I did not think about my
blackness before I'm when I always
living nice you up here because we were
the norm I did not think about it
because now that I live in North
American context I'm constantly reminded
of the fact that death affects people
when I walk through a convenience store
someone's following me I can't just be
like it's because I'm an individual no
it's on the basis of my race and I have
to understand how that's gonna affect
every interaction when you were in
Ethiopia you were the milk
you were the milk no and here you're the
chocolate milk yeah if I tell you to go
to the store and go get some milk I have
to specify if I want chocolate or
strawberry if I just want milk go get me
some milk strawberry milk something yes
I know weird still a [ __ ] thing
you understand what I'm saying it's
still a thing I agree so any dope yeah
you were the milk here not so much you
guys are enjoying today's video be sure
to hit that like button hit that comment
always helps us out with the algorithm a
50% of you watching are not subscribed
so just hit that subscribe button make
sure to not miss our daily videos yeah
even in my relationships man do you
think I want to look at race no but if
I'm let's say for example dating a white
girl and she's gonna introduce me to her
parents not mentioning the fact that I'm
black before I'm like how'd that talk
with them she's like why what do you
mean why they want to know trust me no
they don't I show up and it's a really
racist interaction it's unfair it's not
right I don't want to think about it but
I have to think about it because I know
it's gonna affect my do you know how
awkward it is to meet a man who opens
the door he's like you're the one dating
my daughter and I'm like oh [ __ ] and
then I get these comments about my
culture in my back
it's annoy brother I just want to be
seen as an individual when I joined
something I just want to be seen for my
skill set I don't want to be the
diversity hire I don't want to think
about these things I know what it
doesn't really be the checkbox
just because I feel like I have real
value like you know I am how tall I am I
don't care to get a woman say happy
you're so amazing you're so tall you're
six feet I don't give a [ __ ] but if you
compliment me and you see the value of
me Who I am as an individual it pleases
me because that's something I've chosen
to do and I work on every day in that
same token I feel the same way about
race but unfortunately it affects me
unfortunately it clouds every aspect of
my existence it does when I go in for a
lease man when I'm going in for at least
I slammed that [ __ ] on the table and the
guy was like I don't think I want to
hire then he finds out I'm a veteran all
of a sudden raises me it's like I see
how you know on a societal level so some
veterans that is no back fatty
yo you was just a black dude rough but
then you're a veteran black dude you're
veteran same credit see I applied to
three apartments got rejected for all
three when I met the guy this Fork that
was gonna reject me as well but I've
talked to me like what did you do for
work and then I went into the fact that
I was in the army he's like oh then I
always sunny changed his mind I'm like
hey I can't prove it's about that but
you can kind of feel it sometimes right
it's just yo just Satori you we had we
had you know we my family we had
apartment blocks mm-hmm that's a story
that always like I always remember that
I mean my parents going to the apartment
block right and they were just doing
their thing over there picking up to you
know just sweeping picking up the trash
let's pick some things and and there's
there's this lady that gets out of her
apartment and she's like oh so you're
the concierge my mom is like no no I'm
like oh so nice to see you you too the
poem Sierra's late year not the
concierge forget me something you're the
maintenance lady it's good to see you
here thank you very much for doing the
thing that you do so I'll know I'm not
that I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not uh
I'm not the maintenance lady we're not
meeting where were the owners yeah
the minute she said that my dad got
shoved my mom got called all kinds of
n-words Oh to the minute because now it
was that level you know I mean oh yeah
although you are gonna come here and
take all of our job listen you see
what job are you go are you being stolen
you don't even have a second three okay
and if you get passed by immigrants that
come here and they're able to get a new
education without anything without any
contacts with knowing knowing the
language but having an accent and they
get your job it's because you sucked
yeah so but yeah that that happened
there's a little level about this we're
we're oh yeah yes you're a place but now
you're you know they don't it happens I
don't want to talk about it but that's
the everyday life yeah so that's why we
mention these things in these videos and
that's why we we bring it up because
unfortunately it's part of our existence
don't tell me I don't want to talk about
normal I tell you I don't care you want
to go back to normal life like whenever
I'm saying that other girl and she wants
to tell me about race on my god talk
about they should enough for my job I
don't want to talk about
I'm exhausted at this conversation yeah
but you know people come to me all the
time with like I have I'm so mad about
race and I'm like I'm too tired to be
angry today I'm tired and that's a fact
so you know I just want to share with
that with you guys like that perspective
it's like I assure you I don't want to
harp on this topic it doesn't
interesting it doesn't but unfortunately
it matters and some of you want to go
back to normal well I don't know normal
yeah so now you guys are getting a
glimpse of what our normal looks like
that's the reality
Sarris we want to hear your thoughts
what do you guys think do you guys agree
disagree do you feel like we're doing
too much whatever your thoughts maybe
we'd love to hear them
[Music]